okay so I'm going to be talking about
joint work with the nike son and my
student you mang Jane so apologies to
those of you who've already heard them
give better versions of this talk but
okay so okay so um you know for this
audience I don't need to tell you what a
random constraint satisfaction problem
is we have a you know a bunch of
variables and some constraints I think
like random colorings of random graphs
or random k set and how to use the
constraints randomly okay and no major
theme for this workshop and also the
program as a whole has been connections
to between these sorts of problems and
theoretical physics where they're
studied as you could think of many of
the same problems as dilute main field
spin glass models and and today I'll be
talking about various or trying to make
parts of this theory sort of rigorous
max ok so again i'm sure you almost all
of you know the random case that problem
but let me just say it so that we're
notationally on the same page so we have
n variables true or false and M
constraints will be an or of K variables
or the negations and we'll choose them
uniformly at random so so a three-set
formula would look something like this
with four clauses so and for each clause
we just we choose three of the variables
or the negations uniformly
and of course they get harder and harder
to solve and there are fewer and fewer
solutions the more constraints you have
so you measure the difficulty of it by
the clause density the ratio of
constraints two variables and throughout
the talk i'll call this alpha so the
number of constraints divided by the
number of variables okay and we now know
sort of more and more about cases
including for for large values of K we
know what the satisfiability threshold
it can also be good to think of these
models in terms of a graphical
representation as a spin system on us on
a random Network so if we have say now
say a four step formula we could encode
it as a bipartite factor graph where the
variables are on one side of the graph
and the clauses are on the other and we
just add an edge between the variable
and claws if that variable appears in
the clause you might also label the
edges or color them according to whether
or not they're negated okay and because
we're choosing the clauses at random we
get a random graph and like I get many
models of random graphs it's locally
tree-like so you pick up you pick a
vertex at random look at the local
neighborhood you won't see any short
cycles you'll see a ocm tree
so what do we want to say about random
constraint satisfaction problems well
the like a basic initial question in ask
is for which values of alpha are you
satisfied assignments how many
constraints can you run on and for this
for this question we've you know there's
been sort of substantial progress and in
at least a number of example of problems
we know what the answer is including
various versions of not illegal saft or
random case at large independent sets
and so on and be we could ask further
set knowing the answer to the first
question we could ask further questions
how many when you have solutions how
many are they what are the solutions
look like if you if you pick a random
solution to one of these random
constraint satisfaction problems what
can you say about various local
statistics of it or the overlap between
two randomly chosen ones or
algorithmically can you find them so the
today's talk I want to focus on this
question of how many solutions there are
and in particular what we might call the
the free energy the limit of log of the
number of solutions / in assuming that I
mean first of all we to show that such a
limit exists and then calculate what it
is so that that will be the same and I'm
not going to do it for random case out
look at a the novel equal set model so
this is like case that except you form a
formula in the same way except you ask
that not just that X is a solution to it
but the negation of X is also a solution
so another way of saying that is if we
look at eat any any clause at least one
of them has to evaluate to true
and at least one of them has to evaluate
to false hits the novel equal name and
I'm also going to ask that it's D
regular in the sense that every every
variable appears in exactly d courses
okay so why why study regular not all
equal sap this is doesn't appear at the
top of anyone's list of most interesting
random constraint satisfaction problems
it's you know something like random
colorings of random graphs or random
case out you know more more interesting
well first of all we expected to have
the same sort of set of phase
transitions that these other models that
we might care more about how and the
same kind of general universality
picture should should describe this
model in the same way and secondly it
has some sort of extra bonus nice
features to it that make our life easier
so first of all it's it's binary so
unlike random colorings each variable
can only take has has only two choices
it's also symmetric so if you look at
any variable it's equally likely to be
true and false just I mean that's really
true because if X is a solution then not
the negation of X is also a solution and
thirdly and most importantly it's what I
might call locally homogeneous so if if
we look at the graph that encodes the
the problem and pick a random vertex the
local neighborhood of it looks like a
periodic tree the where the even Rose
the degree D and the odd Rosen the ones
corresponding to the variables of degree
D the ones corresponding to the causes
of degree K so in particular every local
neighborhood looks the same and this is
this is a really helpful feature in the
analysis of these
models and and this is for instance in
understanding say the the satisfiability
threshold for the case that problem the
lack of this local homogeneity is by far
the biggest challenge in that or at
least the part that added the the most
number of pages so so it has these so so
these properties are going to make the
problem easier to study so any questions
about the problem so far okay so what's
the first thing you might want to do in
in terms of counting how many solutions
there are which and all are called Z the
number of solutions the partition
function well the first thing you might
try is just to work out the expected
value and this is a there's a really
easy calculation this is something I'd
like to think my undergraduate
probability students could do but that's
a bit optimistic so every every solution
is equally likely and also the clauses
all act independently so so it's just
this formula which we could write as an
exponential it's e to the n to some
exponent which is a linear function in
alpha so we could just calculate what's
the largest value of alpha for which
this is non-negative and so it's about 2
to the K minus 1 times log 2 so this
certainly at least gives us an upper
bound on the satisfiability threshold I
would and the question is is this the
right sort of is this the right formula
for the free energy okay so first
moments are good for giving upper bounds
second moment sir
good for giving lower bound so we could
check when is the the second moment the
same order as the first moment squared
and because because the various nice
properties the model this works for a
wide range of alpha up to and you can
you can work out how far it works up to
up to this value which is almost the
same as alpha one except this about
one-half less so there's only so there's
a small gap between when the first
moment in the second moment work but
there's still a gap and this this gap is
a hallmark of many of these these
problems in random constraint
satisfaction problems there are there
are ways you can sort of improve this
threshold a bit and Corrigan and then
read over and did that but there's
there's still sort of fundamentally a a
gap you'll get for reasons which I'll
describe and on the next few slides
so the picture that happens is well if
this if the blue line is just 1 over n
Times log of the expected value of Z
will get a linear function alpha 1 is is
its root and this is this you might call
the the replica symmetric solution so we
know it's the right thing below after 2
by the second moment method well it
turns out is that it's correct even
beyond that up to a further threshold
the condensation threshold which I'll
describe in more detail in a few slides
time but after that the the free energy
one over N times Volga said is strictly
less than this than what the expected
value is is predicted up to up to a
threshold alpha sat which I should have
said we was calculated earlier know in a
hater with giemsa
okay so so the expected value doesn't
give the right estimate this in this
range between the condensation threshold
and the satisfiability Thresher okay so
an initial so let me give a first an
initial sketch of why why we should
expect this to fail or the expected
value to be give the wrong picture if I
take a random solution and look at a
typical vertex there's some chance that
it's what I might call free so if i
switch it from true to false it will
still satisfy the equation so it's not
in any any clauses where it's forced to
take take its value and you can show
that for a typical solution we should
expect a constant track like a small but
constant fraction of the variables to be
free and we could take a subset of those
so that they're all sort of at least
distance yes so that none of them share
our core so that they're all also
independent of them so if we have
epsilon times n such variables then
there must be two to the N times epsilon
solutions nearby where we quite just
switching the very values of these free
variables so it says if you have one
solution you should have at least two to
the n epsilon solutions so first of all
that that's saying that the the value of
one on n valk Z has to be at least
epsilon log 2 so there's this kind of a
smallest value this curve could take
which is strictly bigger than 0 okay so
that that immediately says that this
line can't get all the rate alpha 1 but
we'll give a more precise description of
what's going on base
the theory coming from physics but just
just to state the the main result that
the the free energy is first of all it's
well-defined and the the value for the
formula in this there's an explicit
formula which I'll show later on in this
range and it's the one that's predicted
by the one-step replica symmetry
breaking okay and it actually though it
doesn't say this in the result but also
the results is that below the
condensation threshold it's this the
expected value of is the right
prediction that's the the main result so
let me so you know we're saying that the
the prediction from physics is is
correct so let me know describe at least
from a mathematicians point of view how
you how you come to that prediction so
this you know these this is a heuristics
that I used I guess go back to earlier
work on spin glasses and the Sherrington
Kirkpatrick spin glass models but even
even in the 80s that was worked by
Mossad and Parisi on sort of sparse
constraint satisfaction problems and
applying ideas from screen glasses to
those but maybe but more recently as is
sort of a much more complete picture
which might call the the one-step
replica symmetry breaking phase diagram
given by these authors who I think the I
think that all here for this workshop
which
I think well done to the organizers but
yeah so so and unfortunately you have me
to describe it rather than damn it but
yeah so probably many of you have seen
this picture at least 20 times and talks
I know but don't so oh well I'll
described by the aspects of that I want
to focus on today so that so the idea is
if we take you know multiple solutions
to these we can think of two solutions
to a random constraint satisfaction
problem as being adjacent if they differ
in one bit or a small number of bits and
then that gives us the sort of geometry
of what the space that solution look
like and we can say do they come in
connected clusters or are they sort of
isolated from each other and and as we
go from left to right with Nikki of
increasing after the constraint density
so initially and the the space starts
off is well connected after some point
there's a threshold where the solutions
break up into exponentially many
clusters each with only an X naturally
small fraction of the of the solutions
this is a long way from the
satisfiability threshold in most of
these models and much closer to the
satisfiability threshold is this
condensation threshold I mentioned just
now after this the solutions are still
split into exponentially many clusters
but the difference is there apart from
the fact that the free energy is now a
small you know has a phase transition
after this point if you
at the geometry of the solutions another
another thing is that rather than if
most of the solutions should be on just
the largest handful of clusters so you
expect something like the thousand
biggest clusters to have 90 99 percent
of the solutions or something like that
okay and and the final threshold is the
satisfiability one so we'll be
interested in in this raging but the
condensed regime between the
condensation thresholds and satisfied
the lesson one okay so how how do you
say things about about this so I'm going
to do some sort of initially heuristic
calculations that require a couple of
leaps of faith in in performing it but
so the idea is to break up the expected
value of the number of solutions into by
summing it up over clusters and
collecting the clusters according to how
big they are so the contribution of
clusters of slides e to the n times s
where we expect them to be exponentially
large so clusters of about this size and
we'll say that the num the expected
number will be e to the n times Sigma
reverse and you know at the moment I'm
just assuming the existence of such a
function and this is this sometimes
called the the complexity function okay
so if we if we had such a formula what's
cluster size would make the biggest
contribution well it would be the one
that maximizes s plus Sigma of s okay or
alternatively if we if we just drew
Sigma VES we expect it to be concave
that would be the point at which the
derivative is is minus one
and this is this is the picture as it
should look in the clustered regime as
we increase alpha this curve should get
smaller and smaller and at the
condensation transition this should be
the point at which the the second over
the last root of Sigma has derivative
minus 1 and beyond that in the the
condensation regime this tangent point
should be for value that has a strictly
negative value of C we keep going the
satisfiability threshold will be well
what is what is the satisfiability
threshold means the last time you have
any solutions so the last time at which
sigma is non negative for any value of s
of the point at which it's just the
maximum value of Sigma is zero and then
in the unsatisfied regime its Sigma is
just always negative during this we
assuming that the expected number of
clusters replaced accusing ah yes yeah
without yeah and and I'm not justifying
that at this point yeah you're so in
principle this could just be this would
this only gives you an upper bound
unless you assumed a certain I ok so
what happens in the the condensation
regime well ok we said that this the
biggest contribution here comes from the
value of s such that the derivative is
minus one okay but if we look at the
value of s here Sigma reverse is
negative that says the expected number
of clusters of that size is
exponentially small so you don't expect
to see any of them in other words the
expected value is is dominated by an
event that has exponentially small
probability okay so it follows that
the expected value can't be the right
can't give you the right value for the
typical value of upset okay so what what
does well we should take the the biggest
size of clusters that that do exist so
the last time in which Sigma is is the
au- and and this is the prediction we
that it's the the pub the well the free
energy is given by the largest value of
s such that signal is nominal okay so
this would be great if we knew what
Sigma was then then we do we just have
to
okay another another thing I want to
mention is we talked about the you know
what's predicted for the geometry of the
space of solutions in this condensed
regime that most of the solutions are
given in just a small number of clusters
a constant number of clusters so what
why should you expect that well we're
saying that it's classes in this size
that dominate the partition function and
that's ones with Sigma of s equals zero
so the expected number of clusters that
we will see if that size should be of a
constant order and hence you just see
you know most of the contribution to the
mass of the distribution would number of
solutions I mean there are there are
more refined predictions that if you
look at the the largest collection of
clusters you should see a Poisson
Deerslayer distribution amongst their
sizes
there are there are also some challenges
that come in and working in this
condensed regime and that some
quantities are sort of not concentrated
and and it comes from it comes from the
fact that you just have a most of the
mass dominated by a constant number of
clusters so if you looked at z / / its
median say this wouldn't converge to a
constant it would have some non-trivial
distribution which I guess should be
something you could work from a plus on
dear Ashley distribution if if you look
at the overlap between so you pick two
random solutions this will be
concentrated on two points and so like
you pick two solutions you look at the
Hamming distance between them or the
inner product well there's two things
that can happen one is you get two
solutions in the same cluster or you get
two solutions in a different cluster and
and so the you get two different Hamming
distances depending on which one happens
so be concentrated on two points but the
the probabilities of those will depend
on the actual random problem that you've
chosen build and depend on essentially
the proportions in the biggest few
clusters and which will tell you what's
the chance of you know hitting the same
cluster twice essentially so some things
aren't very well concentrated in this
regime and but luckily enough enough
things are that we can still
okay so so the next thing we have to do
is try and get a hand on Sigma okay so
so the first thing is that we should
work with counting clusters rather than
counting solutions and so what is the
what do I mean by saying one step
replica symmetry breaking well there's
various ways in which you could think
about that but one that we find useful
is to say that when you project to
looking at classes rather than the sub
so solutions come in with some structure
they come in clusters but when you look
at the clusters themselves there's no
further structure you don't get clusters
of clusters or complicated things like
that okay and counting the expected
number of classes has been has been
great for working out what the
satisfiability thresholds are the
different models but this isn't enough
for our purpose because we need to look
at accenture not just how many classes
we have but how many clusters we have of
a particular size so the this the
properties of the clusters particularly
their size also matters so what we so
how you could think about this is all
right which we looked at the expected
number of solutions this car sort of
roughly correspond to working out e to
the n times S Plus Sigma of S or working
at this tangent point with derivative
minus one for working out the
satisfiability threshold this was just
counting clusters unweighted so e to the
end times zero times s plus Sigma vessel
or looking at the maximum of this curve
but actually we want this point here
which will have some other derivative
between 0 and minus 1 and so if you
choose lambda to be or if the derivative
is minus lambda then this calculating
the contribution from this point is like
working out e to the end times lambda s
plus Sigma best so if we wait clusters
by their size to the power of lambda
will be able to understand this so so
Zed lambda means something over clusters
of the number of solutions in the
cluster to the power of land and why
would you do this well one thing is this
is just if we work out the free energy
this is a blander you just get back the
Legendre transform of Sigma rivest and
because it's concave we could then
recover Sigma of s so if we could if we
could calculate this quantity then then
we'd be in good shape the so this one
doesn't necessarily look like the
easiest thing to calculate because you
first say take some counting problem now
I group the solutions up into clusters
then I raised them to some non integer
power and add it all up and which might
not immediately sound like a promising
thing to do but it turns out with this
the way solutions are structured it's
that thing that you can you can't carry
out so I promised an explicit formula so
I'm not really going to say say what it
means and not the first the first set of
equations are essentially saying you
solve some fixpoint equation and the way
you can think of this is
saying suppose you have a problem with n
variables and then you want to add
another variable to it well the
distribution around this new variable
should look pretty much like the same as
as all the other ones and so so there
must be some sort of consistency
relationship between things if adding in
going from n variables to n plus 1
variables doesn't change things much so
you get a fixed point equation which is
just these ones and then as you as you
add an extra variable you can say well
how much did this partition function Zeb
lambda changed when we added in a new
variable and you can if you make some
assumptions you you'd get sort of a
calculation that said it should by
plugging this in here and this is this
is also the formulas Atlanta or Sigma
Sigma Atlanta and Nike is going to tell
you more enough going to say it say more
about how you calculate things I hope
I'm not promising too much anyway um so
anyway we get an explicit formula that's
all I I really wanted to say about that
and in the time remaining let me say a
bit about the proof that the upper bound
is kind of standard it follows from
using the interpolation method which was
something developed for the spin glasses
by the wearer and Tana Nellie as adapted
to this sparse setting by friends the
only and panchenko tower ground and now
we're using sort of the regular
that was I guess done in by RT gimana
kin to tally basically what it boils
down to is you get some functional that
you can plug some distribution into and
it will give you an upper bound on the
on the free energy and if you know the
right distribution to plug into it and
the the heuristics coming from physics
tell you what the right distribution
should be then you get the then you get
the right upper bound so so the main
work is to come up with a matching lower
bound to this and that's so this is that
a five percent of the paper and the
doing the lower bound is that is the
remaining
okay so so how do we how do we do that
so essentially what we boiled down to is
we needed to calculate the expected
value of Z lambda this partition
function where we waited clusters by
this the number of solutions to the
power plant so I've been pretty vague so
far about what a cluster of solutions
actually means so we can think of the
following procedure to to start off with
a solution and describe what it's
cluster looks like so we'll add in a new
spin called free so plus and minus will
stand in for true and false and will
call the variable free if if the
variable isn't forced to be either true
or false by any of the clauses that it's
in so if it so if you had a Sabine
I mean ignoring the the negations that
we get this variable would be I could
say would be forced to be a plus because
I can't change it from plus to minus
without violating this this clause so so
we take the we take the variables that
aren't forced and call those free
variables now if if this one if we
decided that this one was free then this
clause would no longer be forcing this
one and so we just iterate this
procedure until until it stops so every
variable will either be true false or
free and and this gives us a new spin
system with with the following rules so
first of all no clusters are violated or
no clauses are violated sorry and but
also free variables can't be forced by
any clauses so you can't have something
where it's false and then all negative
because then it would have to be true
free sorry can't have free not allowed
to have something that looks like
something that looks like this because
this one could only be only be a miner's
and okay so free variables can't be
forced in any clothes and true and false
variables have to be forced by at least
one clause so this is a new spin system
why is this more complicated spin system
better than the original one that we
just had the reason is it's rigid or
locked in the sense that you can't make
small perturbations to it if you just so
if you look at this on say an infinite
tree if you have one solution you can't
make a finite number of changes and get
a new solution the only way you can make
solutions is that if you eat only way
you can perturb it is if you perturb it
on at least a cycle and so and because
we're the graphs we get a locally tree
like that essentially says that there
are no small perturbations we have so if
you have one solution it will be sort of
isolated from other solutions and this
is exactly what you want for the second
moment method to work so that you do if
you have once if you have one cluster
you don't have any nearby okay and and
so this this does give the right notion
of what a cluster should be in
okay now the the free variables you
can't set you can't set them all
independently of each other for instance
if we had it as sort of piece of the
configuration that looked like this
these two variables the left one and the
middle one free variables we couldn't
say set both of these two true because
then in this clause we have it would all
be true and we couldn't set the middle
and right one both to be false so so
there are some dependencies between
between the free variables what we need
to do is group together the free
variables that have dependencies between
them and and if you do that we'll get a
so the free variables will be a sub
graph which will be a forest of small
constant size trees though they look
like sort of very subcritical branching
processes actually most of them will
just be Singleton's and they'll be a
much smaller number of pairs and so on
okay so we have
the pictures we have our graph and then
just occasional and then some free
variables some of them which come in
groups most of them which are just
isolated and then okay and this
represents our cluster so how many how
many solutions are there in the cluster
well it's the number of ways of
assigning these free variables so the
isolated ones can just be true or false
independently of each other so we get
two for each of these but these
connected ones now there are some
dependencies so there might be you have
fewer than four solutions for this pair
fewer than than eight fer for this pair
and we need but there's the some number
of solutions for each group and the
total number of solutions we can get by
just multiplying the number in each of
the groups so to make this into a spin
system where we can calculate things we
we need a sort of richer out a richer
alphabet where rather than just
declaring that a variable is free the
variable also needs to know what the
what the topology of the the tree of
three variables that it's in and also
where in that where it sits in that that
group
okay and so so that gives you a a spin
system with a really large alphabet now
why would we want to make our life this
complicated so the idea is we want to
add in weights to the spin system so
that we can count the number of solution
so that so that when we multiply
together the weights will get the number
of clusters in this in the number of
solutions in this cluster and the way we
can do that is by thinking about the
belief propagation algorithm okay belief
propagation if you remember so this is
an algorithm which people use on
networks to find the marginal
probabilities on on vertices and work
out the partition function it's not
guaranteed to work on on graphs there
can be multiple fixed points and so on
it is guaranteed to work on trees and so
you can use the belief propagation
algorithm work out a set of weights
which you multiply together to give the
number of solutions on a tree so we just
calculate what the corresponding weights
are for each of the variables in these
trees of three variables and take those
to be the weights and then if we
multiply them together we get the size
of the car as as a lender we get by just
summing over these cluster
configurations of w to the power of
lambda which is just like multiplying
these weights to the power of all
together to the power of lambeth so it
gives a spin system with a set of
weights that we can you can try and
analyze
okay and now we just need to work out
the expected value of it and if for
those of you who've done these
calculations of trying to work out the
expected value of a spin system on a
random graph essentially it boils down
to trying to work out what's the best
choice of the empirical distribution so
how many plus and minus and three
variables you have been slightly more
information like on on each edge what
fraction do you have a plus on one side
and a free on the other if you know all
of that then it then you just get a
formula which has a sort of multinomial
term and productive weights and you'll
just get something that's exponential n
times some some function of the
empirical distribution and so you just
need to maximize this empirical
distribution which is then boils down to
a huge multi-dimensional non convex
optimization to do okay but you can do
that by finding fixed points of belief
propagation equations I mean this is so
there's a you know there's lots of
references to this one one place where
it's done in lots of jet generality is a
dembow montanari and some the trouble is
when you do this you need to find fixed
points that are of belief propagation
which fix points of essentially
bi-directional pairs of messages they're
basically okay so this is this is for
the experts but if you belief
propagation gives you a set of messages
that run sort of on every directed edge
in the graph so this will be variables
to clauses and closes two variables and
then so on each half edge you
have messages going in both directions
and then the BP equations would be
finding fixed points of distributions
over those pairs of messages and that's
a really that's something that we've
found to be really hard to solve these
equations so I mean well okay one of the
main technical parts of our work was
essentially finding a way to make it a
belief propagation equation over a
uni-directional set of messages and well
maybe I I think I'm out of time so I
won't
we we take the graph weary sample it and
sort of magically it says that the the
fixed points have to solve some simpler
set of equations so you know there's
lots more questions to try and answer
what can you our models you know this
was the sort of low on the list of most
interesting round of constraint
satisfaction problems can we do it for
sort of one's higher up on the list like
case out colorings of random graphs we
also some of the geometric properties of
our clusters like the that the sizes of
the largest clusters follower Plus on
garishly distribution let me let me
finish thanks all right questions hi
listen the last one you comment that
like that miss you if you write BP you
needa set for this exhibition for Faison
message but actually when you are
running 3 yes take that the two messages
are uncorrelated it'll stay yeah bring
information from very different part of
the season so yeah is your construction
at the end equivalent to assuming yes
the two messages are independent yeah
yeah ah yes nothing what his face when
you are on a loopy grab you when I
looked gravely two messages passing on
the same link and actually correlate ya
know that that's exactly what it boils
down to and the the one whole slide
formula that I had earlier was just just
the what you get from the one
directional message where you make that
assumption if you yeah so another I
guess another way of thinking about it
is
you have messages coming from below the
tree and this this should tell you what
all the messages are in the graph except
that you also need a message coming from
the route we one of the things we do is
to modify the spin system a little bit
so that these trees are free variables
have to force to be at the bounded size
and that's something we can do because
we just want a lower bound and in doing
that it sort of forces the effect of you
know how much this message from the top
can properly get down so that it's only
a constant amount and and that will
imply that this sort of yeah the the
fact that the message from the top is
that if uncorrelated from the
yellow me ask you um these faint
variables form a forest you say yep is
that something that is only true for
high values of K or impersonal should be
true for a low as well that's
yes sorry I should have said all of this
is assuming high values of K yeah in
this only defer that to the physics
friends but I do I I think maybe like
close to the like poison after the
satisfiability Michelle but never much
of a little conversation I mean it it
does if K is big it otherwise no
probably not all right thank you a
question